comment ça va je vais vous parler
aujourd'hui de Xiaomi Xiaomi 13 sur
maîtresse pro alors vous le savez
peut-être mais tous les ans chez omis
sort des nouveaux smartphones enfin très
haut de gamme parce que sur plein de
smartphone énormément d'ailleurs des
fois un peu trop de smartphone mais ça
c'est une autre histoire et ils viennent
de présenter pour la Chine les Xiaomi 13
et 13 pro qu'on retrouvera l'année
prochaine en France probablement annoncé
sortie prévue en France moi de février
donc on a vachement d'avance ce qu'on va
faire tout de suite c'est qu'on va
regarder que propose ces smartphones à
quoi ils ressembleront là où va aller
Xiaomi en 2023 sur le plus haut de gamme
c'est très intéressant de voir
effectivement ce qui annonçait en Chine
alors il y aura peut-être quelques
petites différences en France d'un point
de vue logiciel ça c'est clair le
matériel à mon avis sera le même donc on
va vraiment regarder ce qu'il va avoir
sous le capot et vous allez voir ça va
être super cool allez on y va
bien
alors regardez je vous ai tout mis ici
sur la news room là où on retrouve les
infos sur Xiaomi alors il y a toutes les
infos je les voulais détailler regardez
j'ai un peu la tronche qu'il a ça c'est
xiaom alors je vous ai mis la photo en
grand ici du Xiaomi 13 des couleurs ça
c'est plutôt joli on va voir un blanc on
va avoir un noir on va avoir un espèce
de petit verre un peu clair vert un peu
pastel et cette bleu un peu pastel alors
regardez ça c'est vachement marrant
parce que le bleu en fait il a un côté
un peu granuleux c'est un espèce de faux
cuire ça c'est une espèce d'impression
sur un plastique des grandes guillemets
quand je dis ça parce que je sais pas
exactement quel matériaux ça va être le
truc qui est cool déjà c'est que j'aime
bien ce design avec le module photo
toujours accès vers la gauche ça c'est
pas une nouveauté on le connaissait déjà
on voit bien le partenariat avec Leica
parce que même s'il a été annoncé en
2022 et bien on va l'avoir nous
réellement en 2023 avec ses Xiaomi 13 on
pouvait le voir sur le 12 as ultra
d'ailleurs je vous ai fait une vidéo
allez jeter un coup d'oeil mais on le
voit ici en grand alors il faut savoir
que jusqu'à présent c'était Huawei qui
avait une collab ici avec Leica ça a
changé maintenant et laisser Xiaomi
trois caméras toujours le petit branding
sur le côté comme on est sur une version
chinoise et bien on n'a pas le vous
savez la petite gravure en disant qu'il
y a une certification européenne
fatalement c'est une version chinoise
mais nous on l'aura alors est-ce qu'il
nous le mettrons sur le haut nous le
mettrons ici à ce qui nous le mettrons
ici allez savoir on verra ça donc voilà
déjà un peu le design on voit
effectivement le bouton de volume pour
l'allumer pour l'éteindre grand
classique je pense que lui là ça va être
un capteur d'empreinte digitale aussi
moi qui nous met sur l'écran je sais pas
trop voilà pour la première photo
deuxième image alors ça c'est un truc
qui est vachement intéressant c'est
qu'en fait on voit qu'il a un écran tout
plat ça c'est le survitresse vous allez
voir que 13 pro c'est un peu différent
le Xiaomi 13 il a l'écran qui est
complètement plat ici on voit bien le
petit poinçon donc toujours pas de
techno de caméra sous l'écran ici on
prend pas trop de risques de l'usb-c le
haut-parleur le tiroir de carte SIM qui
se trouve juste là le petit micro qui
est là derrière le micro dessus pour la
réduction de bruit pareil ici donc on va
à peu près la même chose on va de ce
côté là on a rien du tout absolument
rien place nette le petit module photo
qui dépasse alors légèrement incurvé sur
le côté ok bon ça peut être marrant pour
la pour la prise en main ici toujours le
même modèle avec le petit reflet sur le
côté noir qui est sympa alors toi aussi
je viens zoomer je vois ici les infos au
niveau de la photo je voudrais tout à
l'heure parce que je les ai directement
noté sur mon petit papier là j'ai tout
vous dire alors le 13 pro le 13 Pro vous
allez voir il est un peu différent au
niveau du design parce que il est
incurvé incurvé sur l'écran avant et
incurvé normalement également aussi à
l'arrière ici ils ont vraiment voulu
différencier un peu les produits
toujours le poinçon en haut avec la
caméra toujours les trois caméras à
l'arrière donc il y a pas de différence
vous allez voir qu'il y a une différence
sur le capteur principal je vous le dis
dans quelques instants mais sinon c'est
sensiblement la même sensiblement
vraiment sensiblement avec des
guillemets la même config et puis on a
une autre du 13 pro de dos en version
blanc qu'on voit ici alors qu'est-ce que
nous dit cherobi ça c'est un truc qui
est vachement cool alors on va pas se
faire le communiqué de presse on s'en
fout j'ai déjà tout dégrossi on nous dit
qu'on va voir un peu de couleur alors je
vous l'ai dit on va voir effectivement
le blanc le lien on va avoir le bleu et
le vert une différence de poids 189
grammes 229 grammes sur modèle Pro bon
voilà ça se voit pas grand chose
l'épaisseur le modèle Pro sera aussi un
poil plus épais que l'autre mais comme
il est incurvé sur le côté je pense
qu'en termes de prise en main
globalement ça devrait aller des
bordures qui sont aussi assez fines au
niveau du Xiaomi très et très pro sur le
haut et les côtés on va avoir des
bordures je vous ai noté ça de 1,61 mm
et 1,81 en bas ce qui permettra d'avoir
un petit menton donc le menton vous
savez c'est la partie de l'écran que
vous avez tout en bas donc un tout petit
menton et des bordures extrêmement fines
donc ça ça va être assez sympa je pense
globalement alors le truc qui est assez
marrant c'est que sur le modèle 13 ils
vous ont pas annoncé de vercorning
Aurillac glass sur le 13 on aurait a
priori pas vous savez le vercorsing
Aurillac glass c'est un verre qui est
protégé et qui va venir protéger votre
smartphone contre les rayures et les
micro rayures tandis que sur le modèle
Pro vous auriez un verre Corning
auriagas ils ont pas dit lequel donc on
verra ça lors des annonces françaises
alors là où il y a des des différences
vous allez voir c'est à dire que sur on
va se le séparer en deux ici le 13 et
ici le 13 pro il faut de plus vous avez
vu j'écris très mal donc on a des
différences au niveau des tailles des
écrans ici on est sur 6 36 pouces là
c'est du 6 73 pouces on est dans tous
les cas sur une dalle à molette donc
c'est une dalle à molette de Samsung
qu'on retrouve ici on a ici un taux de
rafraîchissement de 120 Hertz sur le 13
qui lui n'est pas adaptatif c'est-à-dire
qu'en fait vous êtes tout le temps en
temps vert donc je pense qu'on aura le
choix entre du 60 120 peut-être du 90
donc vous allez choisir alors pour ceux
qui savent pas Hertz le nombre d'images
que vous avez par seconde et plus vous
avez d'image par seconde et plus vous
aurez de fluidité sur certaines
animations lorsque vous allez bien
scroller et compagnie donc pour le
gaming le 120 Hertz c'est cool lorsque
vous lisez un article que vous regardez
une vidéo ça n'a strictement qu'un
intérêt donc là ça sera du 120 fixe et
comme ici on a une petite technologie en
plus on connaissait déjà sa technologie
ltpo qui nous permettra d'avoir ce qu'on
appelle un taux de rafraîchissement
variable donc votre écran il va venir
varier le nombre d'images par seconde si
vous les un article une image par
seconde sauf que vous allez venir
scroller et si vous jouez un jeu vous
allez monter davantage donc si vous
serez entre 1 à 120 images par seconde
120 Hertz le truc qui est cool c'est que
sur les deux dalles on va avoir
luminosité 1200 litres c'est très
lumineux 1210 mais on va voir un pic de
luminosité le maximum de luminosité vous
pourrez avoir à 1910 alors attention
lorsque vous montez sur des très grosses
luminosité vous allez consommer
davantage au niveau de la batterie donc
l'autonomie descendra mais le truc qui
est cool c'est que si vous êtes en plein
jour et qu'il y a beaucoup de lumière
j'en sais rien moi un grand soleil d'été
par exemple ou alors un grand soleil
sous la neige parce qu'en ce moment
n'est plus sur la neige qu'autre chose
et bien ça devrait aller ça devrait être
donc ça c'est plutôt une bonne nouvelle
aussi une différence au niveau des
résolutions ici on va être sur du Full
HD plus bon sans doutera c'est du 2400
par 1080 pixels et ici on sera sur du
quad HD 3002 par 1440 pixels à savoir
également aussi que le quad HD va venir
consommer davantage que le full HD+ donc
j'imagine que vous allez pouvoir venir
vous moduler directement dans votre
Smartphone vous serez pas obligé de vous
mettre tout le temps en quad HD vous
pourrez rester en full HD+ et lorsque
vous aurez besoin d'une meilleure
définition pour y venir switcher avoir
comment tout ça va s'articuler d'un
point de vue logiciel mais ça on le
verrait quand on le testerait donc on
s'y sera annoncé en France donc une fois
de plus venez vous abonner et actionnez
la cloche comme ça vous saurez tout on
nous annonce ici au niveau du 13 un
ratio écran châssis de 93% ça c'est du
effectivement au petit mort c'est très
bien 93,3% faut être très très précis et
après ils vont plus loin sur le modèle
professionnel avec un delta e qui
inférieur à 1 de 0,29 au niveau de
l'audio pas d'info pas d'infos sur le
Bluetooth alors le truc qui est très
important très très cool c'est que dans
les deux cas vous allez avoir le
processeur que je vous ai présenté il y
a pas longtemps lorsque j'étais parti à
Hawaï il faut absolument que j'achète
des marqueurs c'est le Snapdragon 8
c'est la deuxième génération le gène 2
alors le Jane II il est super cool il va
loin on peut faire plein de choses au
niveau de l'intelligence artificielle
allez voir ma vidéo que je vous ai fait
sur ce processeur parce qu'en fait on
voit vraiment ce qu'on va pouvoir avoir
comme usage là où on va pouvoir aller en
2023 au niveau des smartphones il y a
plein de cas d'usage qui ont été montré
plein de choses très précises et très
concrètes donc une fois de plus allez
jeter un coup d'oeil à ma vidéo je vous
mets un lien par là par là ou dans la
description parce que vraiment vous
allez en savoir davantage et ça c'est
super chouette autre sujet qui est très
très très intéressant ici vous allez
avoir soit 8 Go de RAM soit 12 giga de
ram dans les deux et ici c'est très très
intéressant pourquoi parce que la techno
drame c'est de la elle
pdr5x était présenté l'année dernière en
2021 et alors celle-là pourquoi est-ce
qu'elle est intéressante parce qu'en
fait elle va avoir des plus gros débits
que là LPD R5 qu'on avait jusqu'à
présent alors j'ai noté les chiffres
parce que je les ai pas pris par cœur on
va pouvoir aller jusqu'à 8,5 GB par
seconde donc c'est le volume
d'information qui va passer par seconde
alors que sur la version précédente sur
du 6,4 Gigabit par seconde on sera donc
30% plus rapide que ce qu'on avait avant
donc ça veut dire que ça permettra
d'aller plus loin et ça ne s'arrête pas
là regardez au niveau du stockage dans
les deux cas on va avoir du 128 on va
également avoir du 256 on va également
avoir du 512 et 512 mon petit lapin
comme ça et ici c'est de l'UFS et ça
c'est vachement bien ce que c'est aussi
une toute nouvelle techno c'est de l'UFS
4.0 alors jusqu'à présent on allait sur
l'UFS 3.1 la différence une fois de plus
je l'ai pas pris par coeur en lecture
vous allez être à 4200 Mo par seconde en
lecture donc lorsque vous lisez des
choses de votre stockage directement qui
va s'afficher sur l'écran et lorsque
vous allez venir écrire des informations
directement dans votre stockage vous
êtes à 2800 Mo par seconde on est donc
deux fois plus rapide que l'UFS 3.1 et
ça permettra tout ça de gagner en
énergie que ce soit au niveau de votre
règle que ce soit au niveau de votre
rhum donc si vous prenez la combinaison
ici du Snapdragon 8 Jen 2 la LPD r5x et
de l'uefs 4.0 on va avoir un gain de
performance on va avoir un gain
d'autonomie donc un smartphone qui
devrait aller un peu plus loin je dis
bien devrait une fois de plus voir
comment est-ce que je suis omi et tout
ça il y a pas que les composants qui
comptent il y a aussi tout logiciel
comment c'est intégré donc on va voir on
pourrait aller un peu plus loin au
niveau de l'autonomie et ça devrait
tartiner davantage ça peut être très
très chouette j'ai fait les benchmars
j'en ai parlé sur Instagram TikTok et
Facebook et je l'ai mis également en
YouTube short les benchmarks c'est
vachement prometteur le standard 8 G2
donc ça va être super cool l'année
prochaine donc on devrait aller un peu
plus loin alors après au niveau de la
batterie on va avoir une batterie de
4500 milliampères heure c'est plutôt
cool avec de la recharge filaire 50
watts on va avoir de la recharge dans 67
watts pardon excusez-moi 67 watts c'est
la filaire 50 watts c'est la sans fil et
10 watts c'est la recharge inversée donc
ça c'est plutôt sympa ici c'est du 4820
milliampères heure là on aura de la
recharge filaire 120 watts on aura
toujours de la 50 watts de sans fil et a
priori aussi de la diwat inversée donc
ça c'est plutôt cool normalement ça
devrait tartiner ça veut dire qu'avec de
la watts vous allez recharger une
batterie de 4820 millions par heure en
quelque chose comme 20 minutes à peu
près 18 20 minutes donc ça va aller
vachement vite donc ce qui est cool
c'est que vous voyez on a toute cette
partie là qui permettra d'améliorer
l'autonomie derrière plus de
performances et en même temps vous allez
recharger rapidement donc le modèle Pro
sera vachement plus cool mais déjà la 67
watts ça va très bien donc on a une
recette qui est super sexy en tout cas
sur le papier c'est extrêmement
intéressant alors un petit dernier
détail que je vous ai pas dit pour les
deux c'est que d'un point de vue
logiciel on va voir la dernière version
de miway vous savez c'est l'expérience
logiciel de de Xiaomi c'est mi-way 14
qui va être basé sur un Android Naya 13
donc ça effectivement ça va arriver
l'année prochaine alors je vous
montrerai meway 14 un peu plus tard il
se peut qu'il y ait une différence entre
ce qui sort entre la Chine et l'Inde
toujours un peu la même expérience
logiciel et ce qui va arriver en Europe
ça peut être un peu différent donc on
regarde grâce à l'année prochaine alors
un truc qui est très cool et je vous en
parlais juste avant c'est le partenariat
avec Leica et spartano yallah il est
vachement cool alors effectivement on le
voit ici là vous voyez Leica on le
retrouve d'un côté l'autre mais surtout
ça permet vachement autre chose déjà au
niveau des optiques je vous remets mon
13 et mon pas trop ici regardez vous
avez un grand angle de 50 mégapixels
c'est la Sony mx800 qu'on a notamment vu
sur le Honor 70 tandis qu'en face sur le
modèle Pro on est toujours en 50
mégapixels mais on est sur un autre
capteur on est sur l'immx c'est la 989
de Sony IMX et Sony 989 un capteur de 1
pouce et ça c'est cool pourquoi parce
que le Snapdragon 8 gène 2 vous permet
d'avoir un capteur de 1 pouce alors si
vous suivez la tech vous me dire oui
mais on avait déjà des capteurs de un
pouce avant oui mais il fallait un
coprocesseur d'image là pas besoin de
coprocesseur c'est directement le
syndrigo 8 GN2 qui va gérer ça
directement donc ça permettra d'aller
vachement plus loin en termes de photos
on va voir également un téléobjectif
dans les deux cas ça sera le même ça
sera un 10 mégapixels j'espère que ça
suffira ça on verra j'en sais rien ou on
verra sur un zoom optique x 3 2 et demi
alors il y a un truc à savoir c'est
qu'ici nous a renoncé c'est de l'hyper
stabilisation optique c'est ce qu'ils
appelleront l'hyper oies donc bon j'ai
hâte de voir ce que ça va raconter parce
qu'on connait déjà la stabilisation
optique là elle va aller plus loin hyper
donc à voir ce qu'ils ont vraiment fait
au niveau des composants sur le
objectifs on a également une
stabilisation optique alors c'est un
téléobjectif oui mais c'est également
une capteur qui va être là pour le mode
portrait donc ça ça va être aussi super
chouette c'est un équivalent 75 mm là
c'est du 23 mm et puis vous avez
également un ultra grand-angle ultra
grand-angle de 12 mégapixels avec un
champ de vision de 120 degrés ok ça
c'est triptyque vous l'aurez sur les
trois on a absolument aucune information
sur cette caméra de selfie ni sur le
track sur le 13 pro donc je peux rien
vous dire tout de suite en tout cas tout
ce qui est cool c'est que comme on a ici
un partenariat avec Leica on a deux
modes de colorimétrique Leica on a le
Leica authentique look et on a le Leica
vibrant look en fait ça on l'avait déjà
sur le Xiaomi 12S ultra allez jeter un
coup d'oeil à ma vidéo sur le Xiaomi 12
est ultra parce qu'en fait je pense que
c'est très et très pro vont être très
similaires au 12 et Surat qu'on a vu
cette année enfin 2022 ça dépend quel
moment vous regardez cette vidéo et ce
smartphone je trouvais extrêmement cool
très très performant au niveau de la
photo de la vidéo surtout de la photo
vraiment cool au niveau de la photo vous
avez vraiment passé un cap et donc je
pense que c'est vraiment là où on va
aller cette année enfin l'année
prochaine en 2023 avec les Xiaomi 13
Xiaomi de 13 pro donc ça promet d'avoir
des trucs qui sont supra chouettes
d'autant plus qu'ici ils ont vraiment
mis le paquet alors on peut bien
évidemment venir shooter en rond si vous
êtes photographe hop là donc vous aurez
du rose bien évidemment mais vous allez
avoir du rose ici tout est calibré pour
la suite Adobe donc si vous voulez aller
utiliser Lightroom avec votre fichier
RAW tout est optimisé les aligne les
planètes donc on regardera ça une fois
de plus vous avez tout le travail de
Lakers qui est fait au niveau des
optiques avec tout ce qui va être le
choix colorimétrique on peut en
retrouver d'un point de vue logiciel
donc ici on va voir le matériel les
optiques le capteur tout ce qui va être
logiciel intérieur et nous annonce en
plus de la photographie computationnelle
avec de l'intelligence artificielle donc
le tout mélanger de donner un résultat
qui est super cool alors ça c'est pour
toute la partie photo et vous avez
également de la partie vidéo avec du
Dolby vision donc du HDR et de la 4K
pour venir filmer en 4K 10 bits en loge
c'est-à-dire c'est un profil
colorimétrique complètement plat qui
vous permet lorsque vous venez éditer
vos fichiers je suis Adobe j'imagine
aussi Première Pro sur un Mac Final Cut
Pro ça vous permettra un truc ça vous
permet de venir travailler votre
colorimétrie d'avoir toutes vos bandes
de couleurs rien va être sous-exposé
surexposé vous aurez tout enfin après ça
dépend ce que vous allez faire quand
même à la source parce que vous allez
dire shooter ça vous permettra de tout
retrouver et de pouvoir travailler des
fichiers de qualité entre guillemets des
grands guillemets de qualité
professionnelle ça se trouve ça sera pas
ça mais en tout cas c'est la promesse
c'est la promesse se trouve extrêmement
alléchante alors il y a un autre truc
qui est tout nouveau cette année c'est
qu'ils sont venus nous mettre un truc
qui est très cool c'est la certification
IP68 et on l'avait pas jusqu'à présent
alors IP68 c'est quoi c'est de la
résistance à l'eau et à la poussière
l'idée c'est pas d'aller se loger avec
son smartphone l'idée c'est juste que
lorsque il va tomber dans l'eau si vous
avez un problème qui a de la poussière
un petit peu trop et bien ça va pas
venir l'endommager donc ça c'est
vachement rassurant donc voilà un peu la
fiche technique de ces produits alors
après les tarifs on différentes configs
je vous l'avais dit on aura du 8128 on
aura du 8 256 on va avoir du 12 156
avoir du 12 + 512 pareil de l'autre côté
sur le Xiaomi 13 on devrait arriver à
peu près c'est les prix hors taxes on
fait une conversion des tarifs chinois
ça donne des tarifs hors taxes on n'a
pas du tout toutes les taxes recyclage
doit être des campagnes donc c'est
vraiment très très loin des tarifs
français mais si je peux avoir une
fourchette on dit que c'est du 680 à peu
près dans 550 je vous dis n'importe quoi
590 630 et ici 680 et sur le modèle Pro
on serait davantage à 680
790 et 860 donc là vous me rajoutez 20 %
de TVA et vous moi je dis toutes les
différentes taxes qu'on va voir taxes
recyclage les cils et ça donc bon il
faut imaginer des smartphones qui vont
être peut-être un tour de 900 balles
pour le début et puis on va arriver à
plus de 1000 euros très très largement
ici et donc voilà donc on est quand même
sur le haut du panier très très haut
niveau du panier mais une fiche
technique que je trouve super cool très
très belle promesse au niveau de la
performance avec toutes les dernière
dernier composant qu'on pouvait
retrouver ici dernière technologie pour
beaucoup de performances des batteries
qui sont plutôt correctes à voir très
joli design très beaux écran ça a l'air
en tout cas sur le papier une fois de
plus c'est vraiment sur le papier en
regardant qui sont les différents
fournisseurs au niveau de la photo le
partenariat avec les casques que j'ai vu
avec le 12 Sutra piscine donc c'est vrai
vraiment déchiré l'année prochaine avoir
également ce que je pense qu'on aura
plein d'autres choses on aura toutes les
certifications comme quoi votre
smartphone lutte contre la lumière bleue
au niveau de l'écran probablement chez
SJS on verra donc on regardera tout ça
l'année prochaine je trouve ça très cool
très sympa ça me plaît gate mais vous ce
que vous en pensez en bas dans les
commentaires est-ce que sur le papier ça
vous botte tout ce que nous propose ici
Xiaomi enfin vous proposer je suis au
mur face il nous propose c'est quand
même ce qu'ils annoncent avec les 13 et
13 pro une fois de plus on est que sur
des annonces faites en Chine même si le
hardware sera le même il y aura
probablement quelques petits changements
d'un point de vue software logiciel donc
à vous de me dire ce que vous en pensez
puis tout ça on en reparle bientôt sur
Youtube donc pensez à bien vous abonner
si ce n'est pas déjà fait je vous
embrasse prenez soin de vous à très
bientôt bisous
de l'amour Ciao